عيد الميلاد وقت عيد الميلاد هو سماع
أغاني عيد الميلاد التي تحب أن تسمعها
أفكار الفرح والأمل والبهجة ولكن في
الغالب التسوق والتسوق والتسوق عيد الميلاد
وقت عيد الميلاد هنا
تمامًا كما يحتوي على أغاني الأذن ذات الأنف الأحمر
والأغاني التي نحب سماعها جميعها يتم تشغيلها
آلاف مرات
عيد الميلاد  لقد حان وقت عيد الميلاد في
أغاني عيد الميلاد التي تحبها حتى تفقد
ترانيم عيد الميلاد الخاصة بك على طول الطريق
للحصول على المجانين الذين يفتقدونك، لا يمكنك لعب
الهالوين حتى يوم عيد الميلاد، إنه
أروع وقت في السنة، كنا نركض بجنون
مع هتاف عيد الميلاد، ما هو المزعج
أنت يا صديقي، هذا ليس عدلاً إذا كنت يهوديًا
يهوديًا يهوديًا يهوديًا إجماليًا، فأنت تدرك
أن عيد الميلاد ينقذني فقط من العطلة وأنت
تحاول وضع هذه القوانين أوه انتظر هنا
يأتي سانتا كلوز
أوه عيد
هانوكا سعيد لك عيد حانوكا سعيد،
عيد ميلاد سعيد يا أبي،
كان هذا ساخنًا بعد ذلك  رجل القارة أوه